genius brain listeners this podcast is
brought to you by
nordvpn if you're online doing whatever
you're doing it is none of my business I
really want to know what you're doing it
might be something weird but even if it
is who knows what it is and it's none of
my business and it might not even be
weird it's just something that you like
that I think is really corny but I
wouldn't know it if you just didn't just
go online without using nordvpn how many
times do I have to say it use it my
friends guess what too users can get a
huge discount with the purchase have a
2-year plan plus 4 months free and
that's that nordvpn deal baby exclusive
grab the nordvpn deal now that's at
nordvpn.com genius and get an extra
subscription time try it risk-free now
with a 30-day money back guarantee
thanks to nordvpn for sponsoring our
show genius bra listeners my lovely
lovely brain far this podcast is brought
to you by fume if you don't know what
fume is will let me tell you we're
talking about our sponsored people who
sponsors us fume and they look at the
problem of of bad habits in a different
way not everything in a bad habit is
wrong so instead of drastic
uncomfortable change why not just remove
the bad from your habit fume is an
Innovative awardwinning flavor air
device that does just that instead of
vapor fume uses flavored Air instead of
electronic fume is completely natural
instead of harmful chemicals fume uses
delicious flavors I love the taste of it
it's actually really freaking good
stopping is something we all put off
because it's hard but switching to fume
is easy enjoyable and even fun fume has
served over 150,000 customers and has
thousands of success stories and there's
no reason that can't be you join fume in
accelerating human's breaker from
destructive Habits by picking up the
journey pack today head to tri.com and
use cod genius to to save 10% off when
you get the journey packed today that's
TR f.com and use code genius to save an
additional 10% off your order today what
do you listen to man I listen to all the
things like just just race silence in
his car dude I know you turn on the
music hey don't do that he just goes
home and turns off like a robot just
click
click unplug have a show yeah
I have a show later okay I would like to
be interested in things too I want you
to wrap one song for me okay you don't
think that I would also like to know the
lyrics you don't think I try to memorize
some lyrics you don't think man you
don't think I
Googled Eminem lyrics and try to
memorize it I want you to rap at least
one song okay at 5 4 3 2 1 what's up
everybody welcome to another episode of
The Genius brain podcast we have the
smoking addict Jason chenny and we have
the Long Dong Patricio O'Reilly dude why
do you still smoke cigarettes it's not
cool anymore dude it's the coolest man
really in what way so when you smoke it
you're
like you
know I feel like you're the only person
that still smokes cigarettes yeah
because it's when did you wait did you
start that recently no I I always went
on and off because um I always loved it
yeah I always love smoking cigarettes
since I was pretty young because I I
grew up with my grandfather and my uncle
and they both smoke cigarettes and I
always loved it like um it sounds like
an acceptance speech for for cigarettes
you start my uncles Ando please [__]
sponsor this guy I always loved it when
I smoke cigarettes I feel like I'm
loved it makes me feel calm you know
what I mean like it's just the nicotine
it feels good you're you're not as like
do I mean your butt is not J Ling when
you smoke a
cigarette wait so when you don't smoke a
cigarette your ass just Jiggles all the
time [__] Jiggles and your your body
feels like there's butterflyes so you're
a straight nicotine addict then I am I I
I am how many how many how many
cigarettes do you smoke a day not that
like 3 to seven three to seven a day
yeah that's a lot isn't it oh was that I
don't know I've never smoked a seven a
lot seven is a lot like seven is the
maximum that I'll go seven seven seems
like a decent amount how much are in
pack 20 20 okay yeah so seven yeah seven
seems reduce that down I know I'm trying
to the longest I never smoked was two
years that's great that's what I and I
love I love but I stretched I had to
stretch every night and I still stretch
every night like it just feel I feel
anxious do you know what I mean like
it's like a demon choking my neck like
this want a demon you want to know why
it's cuz you're addicted I know but for
two years I stopped and I didn't you
know what I mean I feel the same way
when I don't have
bread or pasta or rice yeah it feels
like a demon Deo yeah Deo you should
micro do shrooms why don't you try micro
doing shrooms I really want to cuz that
that just take like a little nibble but
every time I've done that it just feels
like you feel like yourself completely
but just the stress any kind of anxiety
you feel is just gone and you just feel
Pleasant you just feel nice I I really
do want to try it man everybody that I
know that has taken it has said great
things about it it's phenomenal right
and they don't do it you know constantly
but they did it during very specific
times of their life where it helped them
you know I mean so I'm like I wonder
what I would happen to me if I took some
shrooms we should do it together we
should it's I I [__] love it dude but
you can't make fun of
me huh what are you going to do is the
question no because I'm going to trip
out and I'm going to be anxious like
weed I'm not going to have a good time
that's what I was afraid of too cuz like
I can't handle weed so I never did
shrooms I was I was like I can't take
weed like I'm going to [__] my pants on
shrooms but then I took shrooms and I
just completely different like I just
felt super happy like it kind of for me
feels like you're drunk kind of like
that drunk feeling but not sloppy like I
don't feel sloppy I feel like just I'm
feel silly but not like you know how
when you're drunk and you're like whoa
[__] and you'll like even like do
something oh that's [__] sloppy I
never felt like that I just felt like
happy Goofy silly and just like really
feeling things things like really like
you feel that's why I think it's
therapeutic cuz like I would have
thoughts or something and like say most
of the thoughts I had were good but
you're dead inside but I'm dead inside
yeah but it woke that [__] up dude but
what if I already feel stuff and then I
do shs now I'm like extra high no but
it's because you work through it you
like kind of like so what happened is
like I would have a thought that would
make me not sad but like kind of a
tougher thought and then I would just
sit there with it and then actually
think about it and then feel it and then
be like oh okay cool it was kind of like
really addressing something and then
like and it would just go away and I'd
be okay now I can just be goofy again
yeah it's nice but you still out here
having origies man what's wrong with an
origy dude okay when was the last time
you took shrooms uh probably like two
months ago probably like two months ago
went to Joshua Tree okay so you saw him
Stars I saw them dude it was we were in
a Jacuzzi I sat in the tub for like four
hours straight body pruny as [__] why I
came out looking like a goddamn raisin
dude my whole body was just
sagging and you enjoyed it very much I
loved it had a great time see I I I got
to try this stuff out man like I don't
typically like hallucinogenics or like
things that kind of like [__] with my
head too much that's why like with weed
I just take it before I sleep like I
don't I'm never like day smoking at all
it's it has a very specific purpose of
helping me sleep but then it's like
listen if I don't have anything that I'm
doing and you know and I want a
psychedelic time why not nibble on a
little stem and see Mike Tyson does it
but that guy's a kind crazy too dude
it's I'm take baby steps cuz like if you
do the micro you'll realize like a micro
is you feel like you just feel good like
there's no actual CH like I don't feel
any changes I just feel like it seems
like what anti-depressants are supposed
to do what they claim to do is what a
micro do of shrooms does it just feels
like I just feel nice like I don't feel
like I'm high at all I don't feel crazy
I'm just feel nice pleasant like oh
things are cool I'm just happy a buddy
of mine who started who started doing
shrooms he was talking about how it kind
of helped him figure out a lot of the
insecurities that he had about himself
that he never like openly faced right so
like he had a lot of issues with like
his family his personal life his
personal relationships his divorce and
everything else and then when he started
like doing shrooms it kind of allowed
him to kind of face all these things he
hated about himself 100% And like I was
like dude that's like some stuff that a
lot of people need you know yeah you
need that no I'm fine I'm just joking
but who would you do it with well I
think
my I don't know I would just have to be
in a in a comfortable space right cuz I
have no inclination right now to do it
but like maybe one day I'll be calling
you guys up hey let's let's try some
shrooms let's do it dude cuz I I don't
mind like I said like so far talking to
most people about it that I know they've
all used it in a control setting with
other people and they've used it like
once or twice and instead it helped them
I'm like oh why the [__] not man like
cuz I I know for other people who smoke
it is a dirty filthy habit that kills
him on the insides and it's a habit that
their children will pick up I I don't
want it I go away I go away Oh They'll
smell it on you they'll see it Daddy
what is that cancer stick in your mouth
why do you smoke that don't you love me
yeah I go okay bye oh my god dude okay
bye absentee Asian father dude I'm going
to get a pack of cigarettes baby I'll
see you in 30 years oh my God you're one
of those dad time dude
back to Daddy or you're grounded forever
damn how that's isn't that story crazy
that's happened so many times that
that's like a thing that we all just
understand the old I'm going to go get a
pack of cigarettes L crazy man see you
in 50 years people just be a I was I was
talking to my buddy about this and we
were making jokes but when I was a kid I
forgot how we got to this joke but there
was essentially like certain like action
figures I call them in your life right
like like Universal truths so we were
talking about this like hey did you ever
have like sticky kid in high school it's
like when you when people say sticky kid
they usually can picture that one kid
that was always eating candy that had
sticky fingers on his hands a wife
beater that was always stained and we
had a couple of those dudes right and so
that led to this conversation I don't
know why I brought this up but I
remember I beat up this foster kid and
like hold on a second what hold on a
second you don't have a
dad let me explain this all right drugs
in your family
I'm a kid too I don't know what a foster
kid is you know what I'm saying but
where I live across the street there was
a lady who was a foster parent and he
lived over there this kid was a [__]
[__] so he would like throw food at
me all the time which I appreciated it
was
delicious I'm mad at you cuz you're not
throwing it in my mouth but he would
like throw food at me he would do that
[__] like the flat tire thing where he
would [__] up your shoes that's annoying
[__] and so I got so [__] mad one
time I just snapped he kept throwing
[__] at me in the cafeteria and I just
started wailing on him in the cafeteria
he started crying it was a whole big
deal and then I just remember I was tell
my friends he goes wait you beat up a
foster kid I was like we were the same
age like it's not like me as an older we
were the same age I don't know what
foster kids are I just think everybody's
living in a house together yeah right
and so like he started making me feel
bad but I was like wait this kid was a
jackass to me though like he would bully
me every [__] day until I just
snapped well connecting to that story I
remember out of nowhere he was just gone
and then his dad popped up apparently
from this is what um the lady across the
street told me I was like oh his
actually dad came back and he came to
get him I'm like what the [__] this guy
just pops up out of [__] nowhere
disappeared out of his life when he was
a kid and then when he's 9 years old he
just like I'm your father and then he
just takes him that's crazy oh how
[__] weird and I remember that kid
was just like gone I never saw him again
but his like Dad who just appeared out
of nowhere to [__] pick them up
that's wild he's one he's one of those
cigarette dad like he just left and came
back he goes now I want to be a dad now
I'm ready that's [__] crazy that's
insane that hurts man to drive away how
come your dad didn't leave you he loves
me yeah I don't know about that dude you
know I was talking about talking to um
some friends about I I think it's really
normal for like Asian families to like
uh the kid live with their grandparents
until older that's like a normal thing
but it's not really in like the white
culture I wouldn't know I don't I don't
know too many white people but like I
know that uh one of my friends we we
just hung out recently she told me that
when when she was a couple of years old
she lived with her grandma for a couple
of years and she doesn't remember too
much of it but at the time like her
parents couldn't afford to take care of
three kids so they put uh one kid with
the grandma in San Francisco yeah and
then their parents took care of the
other two kids and then when the dad
finally got a better job he could like
the mom could afford to stay at home
they brought the other kid so she didn't
stay with the two siblings for the first
two years of her life Wow and then those
two siblings didn't really know her and
then her middle sibling looked at her he
said I remember the first thing she said
to me she looks at me and she goes
Nobody wants you here you're
adopted oh my God D oh my God kids are
[__] brutal dude so [__] mean mean
d they were mean as [__] but that
happens a lot like they call them you
know we mentioned before like parachute
babies where parents just drop off their
kid in the states and they never see
them damn at all like my buddy told me
this story where uh he had a friend I
think he was Taiwanese his parent his
dad was very very rich obviously gets a
citizenship here or whatever whatnot his
mom lives here and they hire a nanny a
Mexican Nanny that dude doesn't speak
any Taiwanese manding only speaks
Spanish and English right later on when
he was in his 20s his mom died doesn't
give a [__] doesn't shed a single
[__] teer his Nanny dies a few years
later after that ruins him [__] wreck
cuz it was like his mom cuz his mom was
there but she just kind had the nanny do
everything and every now and then she
wouldn't take him to school do anything
she was just there shopping doing
whatever but it's like [__] nuts too
where this [__] Asian dude flew in
Spanish yeah hell yeah and I see it in
South past all the time yeah little
white kids right yeah all the [__]
time all the I see like these Asian and
white kids and then I see this like
random like Mexican Nanny mi mi and I'm
like wait what yeah what's going on
Somebody explain to me those are those
are the nannies yeah they'll speak to
him in full Spanish and the kid's like
okay and runs over there some white kid
with blonde cut like what the [__]
dude to [__] go eat yeah perfect the
nannies are are in there dude thean in
there yeah you get bonds with the
nannies for sure they're like eating
Mexican food they know everything their
whole life they grow up with that food
yeah it's trippy as [__] you know South
pass people have a lot of [__] money
and obviously if they're working like
high paying jobs they're out there you
know doing whatever the [__] they're
doing some going got to take care of the
kids and that's where the nanny comes in
and they have like this really it's
weird cuz they have almost it's like a
mom child B it's not like that's the
nanny it's almost like that's my mom
yeah 100% you know what I'm saying like
they're picking up holding them they're
crying asking to be picked up by the
Nanny yeah trippy as [__] Nanny takes
him to school picks them up from school
I've seen that a bunch too breakfast
lunch dinner everything yeah they're
like their moms but what's crazy is that
the nanny probably has a family too is
just that now she's here trying to make
money for the thing and then now is like
this is the kid also like that well I
wonder too like does this nanny also not
have kids of her own cuz she lives at
the house yeah she probably does but
she's taking care of that family but
adopting another do you know what I mean
she has a white n she has a
white teaching them white teaching them
teaching them the the their Mexican
babies just speak English that's it yeah
when you when you go to a Starbucks make
sure the drink is complicated yeah and
nobody can make it and then when they do
it wrong you scream at them yeah I like
oh I get it white culture white culture
amazing wear boat shoes yeah but people
wanted us to talk about the subject it's
probably way past but did you guys grow
up listening to Tupac yes of course you
did in Taiwan no I lied I lied dog you
said that so fast yeah I wanted to I
wanted to assimilate it was ah
assimilate ding ding ding ding ding ding
hey nice nice good yeah good set man
inspirational stuff yeah I want to do
you didn't listen to Tupac growing up no
I did not the first like rap hip-hop
that I heard was 50 Cent Oh that's super
late wow yeah the first was eighth grade
yeah but I loved it but Tupac I later
learned about him and uh to history yeah
a little bit sing your favorite or rap
your favorite uh Tupac
song that's pretty good man that's
pretty good man what song is that called
okay but the thing is I don't know
lyrics yeah but I know the melody okay I
that was not a melody of any Tupac song
at
all yeah see that's how Fred Flintstone
talks yeah daa do no so I want you to
redo that and tup wait wait I'm going to
close my eyes do it again um
my M I'm not gonna lie to you right now
it's my with your eyes closed it sounds
like Tupac in the room like I'm like
damn what Tupac Back this is why I
[__] your [__] you fat [__]
you know that song yeah yeah yeah yeah
that one too you suck so bad dude you
have you suck so
bad you suck so bad as a human dude you
[__] suck so you suck so bad it's
unreal I like duac I hate how much you
suck yeah really yeah I told you get
money yeah you did say mama at the end
of it though I did were you saying Dear
Mama is that the song you were saying
exact the Dear Mama is that what it was
Lady don't you know I love you
sweet oh my god dude okay I do know the
mom was about she was on drugs or
something about the song thing oh wow
anyways here's the important part
important part the the Jee one of the
guys who were the who was the ring
leader
of killing Tupac was finally caught and
so I'm blinking out on his name right
now people who are listening I don't
know why it didn't really shock me so
much because this dude has been going
around he wrote a book about about it
about killing Tupac and apparently he
lives yes about he wrote a whole ass
[__] book about it he was doing
interviews all over the place when who
is this guy uh I can't remember his like
this year this year well he it's been
out for a while he's been doing it for
quite a while like be like uh like all
these like hip hop interviews all this
stuff talking about the [__] but he's
being very careful about not talking
about it he would even have a lawyer off
camera to make sure he's not
self-incriminating himself who so how's
he talking about it without
self-incriminating well he this book was
finally like the last thing I guess or
it was just like he either stopped
talking to legal counsel and he just
started going while doing all these
interviews obviously he's getting paid
for this because what's the whole
purpose of doing this un he just wants
it for clout but Las Vegas apparently
doesn't have a statute of limitations oh
wow so it's been 20 years but Las Vegas
doesn't have that [__] so police show up
he's [__] arrested and he he has
gotten away with it for how long what
statue of limitations yeah so in
California I'm not sure don't quote me
on this but I believe the statue of
limitations is like 20 years right what
does that mean stat so basically you
can't be tried for a crime if if it was
like like after 20 years have passed
okay got it right sorry I interrupt I
just wanted to understand I think for
murder there's probably no is there no I
don't there's no statute of limitations
for murder muckduck also this man's name
was Dwayne Keith Davis Dwayne Keith
Davis I forgot what his hood name was
okay oh
uh I I feel too too uh say it we want to
hear you say it say that but I want you
to say it with the most Urban accd ever
with your chest say it I'm absolutely
not doing that um it I'm just going to
spell it no it's it's okay trust me
Robin Robin say it it's like kef d k e
FF e d kef d ke ke yeah ke I think it's
ke yeah hey you know what that was good
that was good that was good and you know
inspirational it was inspirational
inspiral inspir the other do you use it
was uh use another word robust robust it
was very robust it was very robust yeah
yeah so he's been going around and look
if you got if you were younger right or
if you're Jason chenny and you don't
have any friends um that whole Tupac
[__] was [__] wild at the time like
kids who weren't obviously gang
affiliated right were in this whole East
Coast West Coast drama [__] right we
people people we'd be throwing up West
size I remember I was a kid I couldn't
do this so I'd have to like morph my
hands every day I would practice it I
like you got to make sure you throw up
the Westside C you know yeah so during
that time it's like sug Knight and this
is for I remember when I was younger
it's like Suge Knight and Tupac they
were in Vegas in the casino they went
somewhere else I forgot Tupac got into
an altercation with somebody and B
basically he got a hit called on him and
it was rival gangs it was Bloods versus
Crips like you know you beat up a [__]
right wasn't it a [__] I think so it was
at a casino right because I think like
Tupac was py
so basically Compton Crips pyu don't get
along [__] whole [__] and then Tupac
gets [__] killed nobody knows what
happened nobody knows who did it so this
guy apparently he like commissioned his
the younger homies which was like his
nephew to do it but later on all all
four of them three of them got killed
and he's the last one that's alive wow
so then you can't even incriminate them
for any of this because they're already
dead so obviously through like gang [__]
but yeah the guy finally got caught he
got self in I had no idea there was no
statue limitations for murder that's
saying well I know cuz I was there's a
documentary about the Golden State
killer and like he I I think it was the
Golden State killer and he obviously
murdered people like in the 70s or 80s
and they caught him like two years ago
by using like reverse DNA like they this
is the pat oswal's wife right yes
exactly that documentary it's [__]
crazy D from Sacramento by the way they
went through his trash and like got some
of his DNA and then matched it to like
ancestry.com people and they like broke
they essentially found his cousins and
like brought broke it down to that guy
and it was like a cop he was like a
former cop this guy is [__]
disgusting man like uh so Paton oswal's
wife I believe was either like she was
writing a book or she was a journalist
or something like that right but she
passed away through because she was
taking uh sleeping pills and she had
sleep apnea and basically she is she
affixiated herself to death yeah uh so
[__] sad right um and essentially she
was kind of leading the way to finding
who this guy was because he's still
alive and around and he was doing this
in Sacramento at the time and SA meal
years ago 5050 60 years ago it was a
farm town like nobody really lives that
close to each other it's a super small
town what he would there was like a case
where he would like come into the house
barge in and he would sexually assault
these women in the worst way possible
Right while the husband is there but he
would put the husband into like another
room and put like a stack of plates on
their chest have them lay down and if he
hears the plates move he would [__]
shoot the woman yeah this guy was a
[__] psychopath he was going around
town doing this for years until he just
stopped he ended up getting married
having kids or whatever one of our
buddies actually went to school with his
kids W and everybody thought that their
dad was [__] weird even their kids
thought he was [__] weird W he was
like yeah he was just really odd my
dad's odd like he's not very emotional
like he's just kind of to himself wow so
his kids had a funny feeling about his
own dad too yeah and then when he
finally got caught like the kids were
like yeah it makes sense damn and I'm
not sure if that was like in the
documentary or anything but this is what
I heard from my friend who friend with
the oh my godamn imagine that being your
dad bro you're like damn that was a
golden state killer holy [__] what's up
Papa that's famous no but like this [__]
was crazy like back in the day I feel
like they people got away with so much
things because there wasn't really CCTV
there wasn't technology nowadays you're
not getting away with [__] anything
but the way they found him was like I
said they found like a napkin or
something in his trash can and just
reverse engineered it through
ancestry.com and found him it was
[__] bananas yeah wait I was going to
ask what they can't um so you could
murder somebody and after 20 years they
forgive you no I don't think so not for
murder but there's certain crimes like
say you get in a fight with somebody or
something like maybe I don't know if
assault counts but there's certain
crimes where if you committed it do
matter when after 20 years or whatever
certain amount of time they're like it
does it's it's past the it's expired you
know it's like it doesn't matter that
makes sense why would I think that you
can get away with it just because 20
year pass I'm just like yeah it's okay
yeah what the [__] am I thinking that's
the dumbest thing I've ever said murder
I think is not probably not on the table
for that but anyways that guy you're
talking about that killed Tupac I heard
sh Knight said it was sh Knight for
first of all said that he's known who
killed him the whole time but won't say
say and then now he's saying that it's
not this guy oh really but who yeah I
saw something where he was like they
don't it's not the guy you think it is
yeah but who like just [__] say who
it is man yeah but who who would come
out and say that you know what I mean
like unless it's I just got chills you
know what that means then the person who
killed Tupac is probably in the industry
probably maybe like it's like P didy or
some [__] I don't know it could be some
like that famous Eminem line oh yeah
that P didy killed him yeah ex cuz
that's kind of [__] weird because if
if Suge Knight who
obviously uh managed all like Tupac's
career or whatever whatnot right he says
he knows exactly who it is but he can't
say who it is it's obviously not some
random [__] gangster right right it's
somebody who's in the industry [__]
that's trippy as [__] could be I don't
know man like that Tupac's [__]
craziest thing that he ever did was
after he gets shot he's like gurgling
with blood the the C who went to go save
him to see what happened when he was at
the the crime of the scene or the scene
of the crime the crime of the scene
[__] your English is [__] me up
the scene of the crime right he goes
there and he says that he he's asking
Tupac if he's okay right like what's
going if he's okay if he's fine he looks
at him he's gurgling like with blood
filling up into his lungs he just goes
[__] you to the cop and he dies who Dam
dude that's a [__] G I'm not saying
that's a good thing but you talk about
somebody who sticks with their [__]
guns that's insane he said [__] the
police and he till the even when he's
about to die he goes [__] you and he
dies how Wild is that [__] wow wow I
don't know if I respect that per se or
not that's just the that he was in
character the whole time he was in Char
he was committed committed to the cause
for sure committed to the cause I went
to the Tupac like Museum it was like an
interactive Museum type of thing um and
you get to see all this other stuff
listen I'm not disrespecting Tupac or
anything but this dude wrote a a lot of
[__] shitty poetry in his little book
you see all like the handwriting he was
a lover boy yeah he was like a theater
kid his mother was a black panther like
his whole like backstory to who he is
and how he became who he is like who he
was was it it all makes sense it all
kind of clicks together like in theater
he was he was writing screenplays he had
an idea for like a like a like a a cafe
like a food joint he was he was on his
[__] [__] so like seeing after his
death and mind you he died early he was
like in his early 20s 24 what yeah I
think he was young he was like his 20 he
was in his early 20s when he died and it
was that whole like East Coast West
Coast beef [__] that kind of really
sparked it all off and I'm pretty sure
people who are like more hip-hop
historians they can kind of you know add
more details to this but I just remember
as a kid just how much that affected all
of us for like yo [__] West Coast
music is the best East Coast Music is
[__] trash and it's just spurred from
like this rival that he had between him
and Biggie he was really deep though
yeah and there's like argument too about
like oh who's who was a better rapper
like Tupac or biggie all the time but if
you guys go back like biggie was like
this Lyricist like the way like he would
have word play with his [__] you know
what I mean Tupac was more emotional he
would put a lot of emphasis in his [__]
and make you feel it but biggy's word
play was like Next To None yeah you know
what I'm saying right it was it was just
so [__] different I remember when I
stopped you know I grew up more I was
like I should listen to this west coast
East Coast rap [__] and I listened to
biggie I was hooked I'm like damn Bigg's
a [__] dude lyrically amazing m yeah
lyrically could just put the words
together in I have a feeling you've
never listened to a biggy small song do
a biggy small song right
now what the [__] was that that was him
breathing well cuz he's fat no yeah it
just sleep apne up yeah daytime daytime
sleep apne he did he did breathe heavy
I've seen some interviews with him and I
was like holy [__]
ding you know the
sleep really G about was like Darth
Vader on the mic dude that what's your
favorite biggie song
[Music]
um that was a good one that was a good
one Robin the next time you see Jason
walk up to the studio never let him in
Robin what song was that do you think if
you had a guess what biggie song was he
just doing the melody to I don't even
know it sounded like a commercial jingle
whatever he just
did boom got roasted by the producer
tight that was a State Farm jingle dude
call him an idiot right now Robin
I don't know him that
well it's okay slicker than your average
Papa twist cabbage off Instinct nedward
don't think Instinct nedward pink Gators
my Detroit players yeah Tims for my
Hooligans in Brooklyn dead right if the
head right biggie there every night
every every night Papa been smooth since
days of under rules never lose you never
know you don't know this song I I've
heard it I've heard it it's a classic
Jason Jesus Christ Jason's making it up
hey it was a classic it was a classic
that's what I'm saying you're so good at
avoiding things is amazing your friend
comes off stage that's terrible stand up
wow nice good job that was great do you
like Biggy Smalls classic classic that's
exactly what I do with wine no but you
you know what is I I really wanted to
learn about the thing and when somebody
has passion talk about Biggy Smalls or
tup I I like listening and learning
about the thing but when I'm like not
there I um I just think about other
things dog I love Jason dude he just
descries being a human you know
sometimes when I'm talking to people I
enjoy the conversation but when I'm not
talking to them I'm thinking about other
things like just being a human with
Jason dude just being a [__] human
baby a new show being a human with Jason
being a human with Jason but I really
don't know why like I I'm not like
really invested into like music music or
cuz I would like to know the things it's
just not your thing you just don't like
music I tried huh you don't like music
what do you like I do like music what
kind of music do you like actually I'm
interested no I honestly really like
different types of music weird like
fiddle [__] like fiddle like like weird
circus music or some [__] dude yeah you
that what do you listen to man I listen
to all the things like just just R
silence in his car dude I know you turn
on the music hey don't do that he just
goes home and turns off like a robot
just click click
unplug I have a show
yeah I have a show later okay I would
like to be interested in things too I
want you to rap one song for me okay you
don't think that I would also like to
know the lyrics you don't think I try to
memorize some lyrics you don't think man
you don't think I Googled [__] Eminem
lyrics and try to memorize it I want you
to rap at least one song
okay genius brain listeners this podcast
is brought to you by nordvpn have you
ever been online and you started
wondering does people or does random
shrinkers know what I'm doing online
right now am I snoop snoop snooping
around are they snoop snoop snooping
around the things that I'm doing well
guess what with nordvpn you stay
protected online cyber security is super
important and you should be thinking
about it a lot because how many times
are you on your phone watching something
reading something surfing the web
watching videos whatever that it is
nordvpn gets that cyber security up
there because everybody should use a VPN
if it's not nordvpn what are you doing I
love my nordvpn and whenever I'm going
online doing whatever that it is I have
it on because I need it my personal
information is important out there and
almost anybody can grab it there's ways
for people to get it that you don't even
freaking know so do yourself a favor get
nordvpn users can get a huge discount
with the purchase of a 2-year plan plus
4 months free and my friends here's an
exclusive grab the nordvpn deal
nordvpn.com genius brain and get an
extra subscription time try it risk-free
now with a 30-day money back guarantee
thanks to nor VPN for sponsoring our
show genius brain brain fars this
podcast is brought to you by fume
cutting cold turkey on bad habits is
super hard well guess what we got to
talk about fume because my friends it is
super super amazing we are talking about
a looking at problems in a different way
not everything in a bad habit is wrong
so instead of drastic uncomfortable
change why not just remove the bad habit
from your fume is an Innovative
award-winning flavored air device that
does just that is set Vapor fume uses
flavored Air instead of electronics fume
is completely natural instead of harmful
chemicals fume uses delicious flavors
you get it instead of bad fume is good
it's a habit you're free to enjoy and
makes replacing your bad habit easy your
fume comes with an adjustable airflow
dial and is designed with movable parts
and Magness for fidgeting giving your
fingers a lot to do with uh which is
helpful for de-stressing anxiety while
breaking your habit my friends The Taste
is freaking amazing the look and the
feel of it is pretty freaking cool I
like the weight and the heft it looks
pretty cool it has like this like real
wood natural like shape to it freaking
awesome when I have it in my hand people
ask me what it is I say it's my fume my
friends and I'm breaking bad habits one
fume fume at a time stopping is
something we all put off because it's
hard but switching to fume is easy
enjoyable and even fun fume has served
over 150,000 customers and has thousands
of success stories and there's no reason
that it can't be you join fum and
accelerating Humanity's breakup from
destructive Habits by picking up the
journey pack today had the
trium.vira order
today oh that is not a lap song If you
every time without fil the the national
anthem no okay that's how you know
Jason's a spy dude like just anytime
he's questioned about anything he's just
like oh you talk like a spy dude this's
a spy I know he's a spy dude you always
say things like he's going to be super
profound but you're just explaining
things that regular people do hey hey
let me tell you something okay when I
put food in my mouth I
chew and then that's and then later on
maybe I go to sleep good timing maybe I
go to one song all right um
uh
lollipop you take me to the candy
shop you really only L to listen to 50
Cent do you like 50 Cent I do like 50
Cent okay yeah then rap a [__] 50
Cent song I just did
it
um oh my God you don't think Hardy to
Remember lyrics is the thing what's the
song any song that you like any song
okay what do you like what are you
listening to right now oh New World okay
the new one uh is the greatest showman
what's that this is the greatest
show that's not new what is it's a new
one like it's like four years old how
was that new that you said it's four
years old it's it's it's new to me it's
[__] perspective man dude Jason's an
alien dude you really are an alien dude
I You're an Alien that came to Earth and
you're like trying hard it is to try to
be normal show me your immigration
papers you're like the first model of Al
like the first iPhone that came out they
like working the bugs out they're like
the first alien they said you're not a
real [__] I am a real person to just
gather data speaking of [__] aliens
dude you know what's so hilarious your
people have to respond back to that
[__] jacked up Mexican alien that
they found what the [__] is that dude
it's crazy that no one it just no one
gave a [__] at all instantly was like
that looks [__] to me dude these
guys come out they go so we found one
Mexico they had in
little so we got one so got one so we
got one uh I don't know if you know this
but we have
one uh we can't we can't give you
samples or anything like that but like
hey it's right here dude they're holding
it in the neck like is a
chicken they go it's a good one is it
it's a good one is it we got it in Miami
and we got it in Miami Miami there's
three there's three when I saw that [__]
it I was like okay what in the [__] how
are we supposed to believe that this is
an alien and it looks like the aliens
from Men In Black yeah yeah yeah it look
like [__] and then they're just like
oh this was preserved okay also too it
has every like pheno is it the word
phenotype the the genetic expression
that you see outside like the phen like
a mouth a nose and eyes like us are we
supposed to believe that this is a
[__] alien it was the saddest thing
ever what is going on with Mexico right
now dude I don't I heard that they they
they discovered it at like an ancient
like tribal area or like a campsite or
something like that and they think that
some people think that it's like oh they
were just like artifacts that this tribe
made a long time ago and then they're
like oh these are aliens I don't know
but instant it was funny to me that
everyone instantly was like that looks
like [__] that's [__] [__] no
traction they had suits on hey no
disrespect to Suits on like it was
serious no disrespect to Asian people I
you can probably go to Japan and find a
couple of grandpas that look like that
right now I'm just saying dude it looks
like an old Asian Grandpa and I was just
so upset they like they just found an
Asian person and he's just like sleeping
and they just picked him up he's like
[__] we have
there and this Japanese gu wakes up
hello hello is my
home I used to wake up Mexico Mex he
rolls out of the casket I know this is
[__]
me back into my home yeah I don't know
what that was dud but yeah you don't
hear it it's just like but they made
like national news out of it they're
like hey we found a [__] alien like
it was like an inyour face to everybody
else in the world like oh you oh you
guys got Elon Musk we got this [__]
Alien made out of cake yeah yeah yeah
yeah but no no press is bad press cuz
now we we talk everybody talk about the
thing and maybe next time if they find a
real alien they go I just King about the
last one but this one real one this one
real one and hey
it's okay like whatever all right just
[__] leave it alone whatever man I
don't care but listen what the [__] man
I was actually kind of disappointed
because there's been so many alien top
now where people are like finding these
spaceships in the sky you know because
we have all this recording and [__] now
now we could actually see it for
ourselves and before people would just
tell these stories but you can't confirm
it but now you see an actual video
recordings of these objects next to a
plane that [__] just disappear they
go straight up in the air I'm like
that's what the [__] is that so I've
I've gone pretty deep on the alien [__]
I've gone pretty deep yeah cuz I was
like H let's see what's going on and
I've I've like listened to a lot of
[__] talk about it and you hear
psychos that are like these fools are
clearly crazy and then other dudes were
like oh that's interesting like there's
some I like absorbing all of it and I'm
just even as a story even if it's not
true like this is just a good [__]
story yeah like there's this one dude
that claims to have like had contact
with aliens and this is his thing all
right some dude named Steven Greer uh he
says that you can communicate with them
through a level of thought so like they
do everything through thought like they
communicate through thought they move
through thought spaceships move through
thought and he if he's like if you
meditate enough you You Reach This Plane
of thought where you can actually
communicate with these beings sounds
crazy if this was a movie I'd be like
that's pretty dope dude I'm already on
board but he talked about how uh what
was he saying he was saying that um that
humans have found alien technology a
long time ago and have been kind of
working on it like secret scop [__] and
that some of the stuff you see right now
human [__] that they're just like kind
of like doing uh he's like there's real
aliens he's like there's like 80 species
that we know of he's like but there's
human [__] and like they you know
sometimes they're kind of flexing to
other countries like flexing to Russia
or flexing or like it could be Russia
flexing there like just new technology
that were flexing like hey we got this
[__] if you guys try to [__] around we
have that and it's like one of those
things that you're talking about um but
his whole thing was that there's like
they're trying to create like a a like a
a this is where it gets like conspiracy
theorist they Theory or whatever the
[__] uh he was like they're just trying
to create a false flag with like a human
version of it to just get people to be
like oh [__] there's an alien attack and
then they can do whatever the [__] they
want that's where he kind of starts
going down that road but I'm like that's
interesting and then you hear other guys
that talk about just like how the
spaceships moves some guys say that they
found it from ancient digs you got the
guy that with the sunburn that's like
aliens from Ancient Aliens who's always
[__] ridiculous to listen to but dude
there's a lot of information out there
and who knows I mean but they say it's
real the government say the government
says there [__] that we don't know like
that that there's uaps which are UFOs
there's The Whistleblower that came out
from I think he was in the Air Force the
guy that actually went did a hearing in
Congress um but what makes me feel like
when like it's so hard to trust like
mainstream news that like whenever they
say something I'm kind of it makes me
feel like it makes me just anytime they
say anything I'm kind of thinking the
opposite I'm like there's I feel like
the opposite is true so you think
there's no aliens I think there is
aliens but I just I don't know
like I just there's always an angle you
know like they're always like trying to
angle something so I'm always like what
what's going on with all that [__]
that's wild as [__] so it's saying like
if you meditate hard enough you could
talk to a [__] alien I would love it
and I mean you're pretty much there
you're brain you're a [__] alien dude
we're talking Ali right now to us dude
like yeah I would love
it alien you're a [__] alien dud
You're an Alien dude that's why you want
to eat all that cheep skin [__] soup
and [__] all that [__] organic
of my hometown meals planet of zerog out
of a Home Depot bu some white Home Depot
bu about this right
now kill the fat
one dude yeah I've I I only started
reading a little bit about the the whole
alien thing because this whole thing
popped up and then now people are
putting all this footage together and
there was that theory of okay maybe this
is Tech that the US government had has
that they're not telling and then when
it h when people are seeing it they just
the US government's covering up and like
yeah there's aliens guys it's aliens
right but you're saying it's a deeper
level of no that's actually alien
technology that they're [__] around
with so so there's guys like Bob Lazar
is a big one right so he came out in the
80s that he worked at some secret
facility in New Mexico I think it was
and he came out and he basically was
said that he was brought on as an
engineer to reverse to reverse engineer
spacecraft that they had found in
ancient digs so they basically what his
role was like they found a ship and they
brought a bunch of Engineers saying how
does this work and they basically were
trying to have them [__] with the ships
to just figure out how this works so
that they could apply it to their own
technology that's like what he said
humans were doing in the 80s um and he
came out cuz people were like why are
you say like why what why would you come
out and say this and he was like cuz his
phones were tapped and stuff like that
and he felt like his life was threatened
so he has like a defense he was like
this is like insurance for me like I'm
saying this [__] so if I die you know
like it's like there's a risk to killing
me now that was his whole story but if
that's true that they were reverse
engineering uh technology which I mean
look if we did find a spacecraft we put
we would try to figure out how it worked
and that was in the 80s like imagine
what it's [__] 30 40 50 years later
like the kind of [__] they would have
now it'd be [__] insane it'd be
insane well why don't we use some of the
things well they probably do but they
that's the thing is like so another guy
the the Steven Greer guy was like some
of this technology that they have and
like I said this is just his point of it
could be [__] whatever but he's
saying and this also kind of makes sense
to me though is like that some of the
technology has the power to
completely revolutionize our our
civilization we wouldn't need oil we
wouldn't need like you would just like
we we'd be so abundant like all these
multi-millionaire billionaire dudes
would lose so much money okay he's like
and that's why like they don't want to
do that and like I said true or not if
that capacity of te if that kind of
Technology existed fools in power would
for sure not want that to happen like
that's just a human thing where you know
like dudes in power would not want that
to be exposed just kill them all dude
just kill them all dog yeah man I think
that's a great idea it's never been done
in history before who the the people in
power no just kill people you don't like
kill people you don't like yeah there
you go it's like what you're definitely
an alien dude dude's an alien D you're a
[__] alien right now why say that
look at you you don't even know what's
going on oh yeah you're not what's that
commun right now you saw that [__]
he's [__] communicating right now
code right now I told you what you say
just
now you know I'm going to tell my alien
friends everyone just H we're talking so
much [__] about you you just taking a
nap I'm G do that to my wife every time
she talks to me about some [__] I don't
want to hear about yeah hey hold on I'm
talking to my alien friends just break
down we're talking so much [__] in the
chat about
you but like when I when we like
technology has been so [__] crazy now
where like I even the other day like I
have this iPhone 11 Pro Max I haven't
upgraded it since and I was like I don't
need to cuz the phone works fine but
then I see somebody with a new iPhone
and I'm like holy [__] my thing is
garbage like it is garbage compared to
your phone like Tech grows so fast now
like when we were younger when we wanted
when something new popped off we had to
wait a long time for it yeah now it's
like a new iPhone every [__] year
every day yeah here you go here's
something new like oh if you get this
iPhone 14 well next spring there's going
to be an iPhone 15 right like dog you
just can't stop buying things left and
right and like Tech technolog is
advancing so [__] fast even like M
like film and movie we we used to have
to wait like [__] two years for like
a videotape right but now it goes Movie
3 months later DVD Hulu all this online
[__] like before I feel like Netflix was
I don't know maybe it's because it's so
saturated like now it's so hard to find
a show that you want to watch and get
into yeah we definitely have too much
man I I finally watched The Shane Gillis
uh special beautiful do it's really good
dud so I think it's probably one of the
best standup specials this year did you
like the first one or the second one
more they were both funny they're both
great which is very hard to do like
usually you get the wow factor of the
first one and the second one's kind of
like me but they're both [__] fny
he's a beast dude it's kind of crazy
watching him right so like years ago
like I did this video uh just kind of
like talking [__] about him because of
that like podcasting that came out right
and like even like now if I look back at
the video I still didn't like it because
uh you know he was calling us chins and
I didn't like that [__] yeah I mean like
there's like certain lines you don't
cross especially if it's not there's no
joke in it like he didn't make a joke
that was the problem with me right it's
like oh like say what you want but you
can't call us chins like that's like
[__] crazy that's some wild [__] and
so like when I looked back at it I was
like I just didn't know what was funny
about what he was saying you know I mean
it's like I don't know where the punch
line is cuz I'm always looking for the
punch line and so that kind of put like
a sour taste in my mouth right I was
like this [__] weird dude
and then lo and behold I see him pop up
I see his sketch comedy show I'm like
I'm [__]
laughing I'm [__] laughing why am I
laughing that this guy's hilarious right
I'm [__] laughing right I'm like I
hate that I'm laughing and I'm wishing I
would have thought of this cuz it's so
[__] funny right and then you know he
brings out the special on YouTube and
I'm like this is the funniest [__] I've
seen in a long time it's making me mad
that I'm so this so [__] funny I'm
having a great time yeah stop turning me
into a fan you [__] idiot but then
that's the thing like his comedy is
undeniable like like you I'm I'm you
know we all say very you know unpleasant
or unfavorable things especially when
you're on a podcast format right like
you're trying to make so many [__]
jokes like you kind of forget that
you're talking to an audience and I've
done this like multiple time on this
podcast right or just like you know
spitballing stupid jokes and ideas
whether they're inappropriate or
appropriate or not and I know I think
when I look back at it it's like maybe
he got kind of caught up on that [__] as
well right because now when you look at
his like racial jokes they're a lot more
nuanced like that [__] wasn't nuanced at
all but he's obviously evolved since
then and now when he makes like these
racial or you know sexual jokes there's
Nuance to it where like everybody can
laugh about it right well I think what
it is too is like we kind of understand
who he is now so so it's almost like the
equivalent of like for with you guys for
example like I'm close to you guys you
guys we know each other I know I can say
some wild [__] to you guys and you know
I don't it cuz you know me I know every
time you say the NW is like really rude
you can't
say you can't say it that many times hey
man he just comes out what's up M hey
that's in private dude talk about that
[__] dude but anyways so uh yeah but you
know what I mean Jason is kidding by the
way I'm kidding he's that serious I take
it but so I think like in that situation
cuz it was him and his buddy and you're
right it wasn't nuanced but I think they
probably were like at the level where
they can say some wild [__] to each
other and they know in their world they
don't mean it but and they know each
other but you're right there's an
audience listening and you you if it's
not Nuance it's just like you're like
what the [__] is this fo talking about
right but now we know him right so like
even in the new special he has a joke
about being in Australia and how like
there's no black people there and how
it's like white people have take crazy
chances because there's no black people
set him straight and then he has a line
where he's like yeah and I know what
you're thinking like no black people and
he's like kind of like
like that's sick you know and then he
jokes obviously he's jok that's a racist
[__] joke but we know him now so it's
not you know mean but then he also like
completed the joke and made it full
circle right and I think with that
podcast he made a big mistake because
when I was listening to it nothing went
full circle it just stopped right like
what the [__] were you doing like you
should have made a joke out of this and
so that's why people were pissed and I
think like the the thing that kind of
allowed me to like like I said who the
[__] cares if I approve or not but it
was just like he never doubled down he
didn't say like no it's right
he double down he's like a I kind of
like that was kind of poor taste you
know what I'm saying so it's like Ah
that's fine it's kind of hard to defend
that yeah really have much to say you
know he's like yeah I didn't I didn't do
like a full circle joke here you know I
just kind of threw that word out there
and I just left it you know I mean so
but yeah when I watched this like second
special I'm like damn he just he has
that thing he has that [__] it Factor
you know what I mean where he is so
undeniably like himself on stage and
it's just [__] hilarious like I don't
know why I'm [__] laughing so much at
the [__] he said is like this is a goofy
[__] guy he's so goofy and very smart
right right well and also he's so good
at at he he can touch Bas in both worlds
yeah so he's got like the the you know
he can he can make he can make like
politically yeah anything but I'm saying
like he can appeal to kower more liberal
and conservative because he has a
conservative background and he makes fun
of everybody and it's not everybody can
get it everyone can get it but he's also
more he's not just pandering cuz there's
a lot of comics that just Pander and I
hate that [__] where like they just say
something in a crowd that's why I like
your gun bit cuz like it's it's not it's
especially in California it's hard to
talk about being pro goun you know what
I mean but you don't you're not out
there like I'm Pro goun you make fun of
both sides but like you're you're
bringing them into a world that they're
uncomfortable with and then they're
happy that they're there right Shang
Gillis does that perfectly dude like
where he can he can touch base on the
conservative side the liberal side and
he makes fun of everybody and then it's
just kind of like uh like everyone's
just cool you know what I mean so he's
special in that sense too 100% And like
you know when I see like these people
like you know I think we're just getting
older now too where I just I'm not as
critical as people as I used to be when
I was younger cuz like when you're
younger you're just pissed and angry
about everything sometimes you just want
to [__] laugh right yeah as long as
like I feel like comedy 2 during
pandemic was so rough right people
couldn't perform everybody was so
[__] hyper sensitive about everything
you made a joke that kind of rubbed you
the wrong way somebody would write an
article on [__] trash ass vulture
about it you know what I'm saying like
what what kind of world do we live in
now where like comedy can't be explored
and I'm not saying that it's not going
to be offensive I'm not saying I haven't
been offended by comedy too yeah right
but I've seen people work their material
where they got better with it they made
it more nuance and it kind of gives him
an opportunity to do something right
like I yeah I just feel like the
intention is to be funny yeah yeah yeah
yeah sometimes people forget that it's
like we're just trying to do our best to
make you laugh and have a good time and
just remember how bad [__] the newer
Comics that came out were just just as a
as a [__] sobering reminder how bad
was their standup when they Pander to a
crowd and they're just trying to make a
joke about nothing yeah they want to
clap they want to clap they want social
justice [__] right and weal I talked on
a previous podcast like Hassan minhash
right damn that's that guy's trash
that's that guy's been trash he's trash
since day one dude I me of course he
doesn't want to say you don't have to
inspirational I know inspirational dude
inspiration insirational dude that guy's
come on dude he [__] do two people
[__] ruined two people's lives people
that he knew that was his friends all
everything's all fake made up fake
social situations made up fake hate
crime stuff so he could look good as a
human being and he made no jokes anyone
that goes out and even he's doing a
special though he's doing the special
doing the comedy he was a comedy special
but was funny okay okay but let me ask
you but he's trying to be funny but what
what is's not trying to be funny though
I can't stand ping ass [__] dude trying
to make himself look good yeah exactly
that the vanity of it the P the the Pand
what is the line what is the line of how
much you can exaggerate in in comedy he
didn't exaggerate he just lied no no but
about real people the thing is you I
know but what is the line of lying and
exaggerating you can lie dude I have no
problem with lying or exaggerating
comedy we all make [__] up and if it's
funny but like if you're just making up
the like the anthrax thing like a story
to about like what what the anthrax [__]
to just make people feel bad about you
and then there's no an I actually don't
know about I don't know the specifics of
it this is what it is right so he's
getting called out because there was a
journalist who wanted to do a piece on
him and what this what this journalist
found out was that everything he did was
a [__] lie and he said well 70% of my
material is emotional truth what the
[__] is emotional truth emotional truth
is it didn't happen it Li so he's trying
to bend he's doing word play semantics
so for example the anth thing was that
he said that because of his standup
comedy he got in envelope full of
Anthrax right and it went on to his
daughter and then his wife looked at him
and goes you could make all your
political comedy wherever you want but
if it affects my life and our family
then I'll [__] leave you that's not a
joke there's no joke it's almost like
remember Steve Rizzy said he was a 911
remember that do you know about that
there's a comic named Steve Ren know
yeah yeah so he he had this for a long
time this story about how he was like at
911 he was in the towers and like he had
I I don't remember the specifics but
essentially that he had like this heroic
story about how he was there six years
down the line it came out that that
wasn't true it was a complete lie and
everyone and now everyone roasts his ass
for it and he like takes it like a champ
he's like I think what happened is he he
told a story and then he it like people
started he started getting attention
he's like oh [__] I'm in too deep and he
probably just kept the LIE going but
what I what I mean and he doesn't seem
like a scumbag like that but but it's
just like you if you're making up a
story just to like get brownie points
like if you're not
using for for yeah if you're not using
it for comedic effects and it's just
like a horrible thing that Happ like why
would you do but the joke is coming
later but there was no joke it's like
saying like you didn't watch the special
I watched the special I it took 12 hours
to watch it cuz it was so bad if there's
a joke at the end of it dude if there's
a joke at the end of it say whatever the
[__] you want but it was a special
though so there's a joke coming in like
[__] 2 minutes or however long that's
like me there was no special that's like
me saying like dude that's like me being
like I've been I've been molested like
and I just want you to feel bad about to
you like I just I'm just like I've been
molested and then I I like I talk about
like what it's like to be a guy that's
been molested and then you find out 10
years later to you like this right
there's nothing funny Dave Chappelle did
in his special he did a he had a
conversation piece about his trans
friend who committed suicide right yeah
and there wasn't really much jokes to it
it was a a personal story that he told
now if Dave Chappelle said but that
never existed that person wasn't real
yeah and his reason was like well it
happens to real people so what's the
problem well the problem is is that now
you're taking like real life situations
with real life people and and as not AIS
I'm sorry uh steeve no not steeve
AI other Indian dude H minhaj right he
used real life people these These are
people that actually [__] exist right
oh these are real people this isn't a
madeup person okay if it's a I know put
their [__] picture up on his [__]
T
talk and also but it's also that plus
his entire character of the guy that's
trying to Pander and like you know what
I mean like cuz if look at how I bullied
like I'm know even if Chappelle like
even if Chappelle came out and was like
um that trans story is not true right we
we'd kind of be like oh that's kind of
whack yeah but Chappelle is not the kind
of guy that goes up there and just
trying to get you to clap along like
he'll say some [__] that's real and
he'll tell you it would almost even
though that's like a the [__] a wrong
thing to do it would be counterbalanced
with his character as a whole and you'd
be like that was whack but he's still
pretty cool because he does this but if
your whole character is if you're doing
[__] like that political comedy and
you're like this isn't feel bad about me
but then also your whole Persona is that
you're like this is what is you're whack
I'll put too like for me there are
things that like people real people go
and I said this on the last podcast
right how many people that we know like
obviously we make jokes or whatever what
not right but on a serious note there
are people who really do get like
sexually assaulted like let's say for an
example like you were talking about that
guy who was an 18-year-old who got like
sexually assaulted right now that in of
itself is a terrible thing that happened
right and then we had this conversation
and then but later on he does like this
whole thing people are coming up to him
saying oh dude I'm so sorry that
happened to you and basically he gains
popularity because he's pandering to
this thing of like a real life tragedy
that happened to to real people yeah
real people he get money from it he gets
Fame from it success right and then
everybody feels bad about and all and
all a he goes oh by the way it wasn't
real and also if it's real people that's
[__] up because it's like it is real
people and also there's no joke like
where's the funny part I didn't know but
I didn't know there that I didn't I
watched like parts of it but the um but
if if like movies or TV series they will
make up things and go this is fiction
like Marvel people are flying yeah he's
saying it's real so for example I didn't
know that exactly so he saying it's real
so let me tell you so there was another
part too where there was a girl when it
affects others and other people are
getting hurt there was girl she got
[__] docks and she got ripped into
people are finding where she lives all
of her personal information and it was
his friend so it was a girl that he said
that his he wanted to go out to prom
with her and there was oh yeah and then
her parents were like no because he's a
brown guy I don't want you and he made
this whole emotional statement of like
well look now like Look At Me Now blah
blah blah blah never [__] happened
that girl he invited to that show and he
put her picture up there and just
slightly blurred her face in her
husband's face she got [__] found and
got doxed it's a real person her life
got like [__] over for that [__] if
people are getting hurt that's not cool
well so the real story was is that she
already had a date and then she couldn't
go she married she married like a
Southeast Asian guy yeah yeah so she
came out looking like this racist her
family came out looking like a bunch of
racist bastards and it's a real person
but but but it's it's using it's what's
shitty is like you're using something
that's really painful and like like
racism and you're using it for your
personal benefit and that's [__]
whack like that's whack now if you use
it in the cont if you use racism or
whatever and then you make it funny
because you're a comedian okay fine but
if he's saying a thing about the racism
thing and at the end his end like
conclusion is like hey but don't be
bullied and other people feel empowered
not to be bullied by racism and if it's
a fake Story by fake people then I'm
like okay it's like a Disney movie it's
nice but then you're not a comedian and
why are you doing standup go do a TED
Talk exactly he he wasn't doing stand up
he was doing you hear the laughs inside
the thing I always try to I always try
to give the benefit of that listen when
I when I first listened to his uh quote
unquote special right I actually didn't
know it was a special I thought it was a
TED Talk and so when I I didn't know who
he was I heard of him I listened to it I
was like I don't want to listen to this
Ted Talk and so I turned it off and then
a friend came to me and he was like oh
did you watch uh Hassan minhaj special I
was like oh I didn't know he also
brought out a special and he sent me the
link to the Netflix thing and I was like
wait that's the same thing I saw I was
like no I said a special he was like
that is a special I'm like how was that
a special there's no jokes it's like a
TED talk so it's like but you know AR
Spears and like even a bunch of other
Like Comics said too they're like what
happened the comedy where you're
supposed to make people laugh like now
people are just here talking about their
trauma on stage I I was talking to
another comic about this I feel like
even 6 years ago the pressure of getting
laughs and hard laughs was higher than
now I feel like now I forgot which comic
was saying that now you the setup just
has to be a little longer to so that we
don't get but I miss it
the about that me laugh dude [__]
laugh you I'm talking about I do know
what you're talking like before like
five six even seven years ago it was
like laughing was the point like
whatever you say you have to just but
now it's like the the pressure of
getting the laughs is not as high as
before I feel like yeah do you feel that
yeah no 100 it seems like it's not the
main priority it's like it's which it
should be yeah it should be like make
mother look I it's I'm not no one to be
like the comedy police and how you
should do comedy everyone has their
style you do whatever the [__] you want
to do and there's nothing wrong with
being emotional or talking about real
[__] that's happening to you there's
guys like Ali what's the what's his name
Ali sad sadik Ali sadik yeah yeah black
dude right that dude is incredible and
he'll go into stories like about like he
had this one stor about how he shot a
guy went to jail blah blah blah but he
and it was intense and there's moments
where like it's [__] you can hear a
pin drop in there cuz he's literally
talking about shooting this guy that he
tried to kill and he's he's angry and
like it's aggressive and you're like
holy [__] and then but he he brings you
out of it makes it [__] hilarious and
you're like the emotional payoff of that
whole journey was sick down but that's
his style he's doing it and he's also
not doing it to be like comedy is a
rebellious art form you know what I mean
in it's in its nature it's like it's the
the jester told the king the truth and
he was funny and it was it Ruffles
feathers that's what it is so when a guy
goes up there just to like for like
vanity purposes yeah or his therapy or
his vanity purposes or just to be like
look guys how good I am it's like that's
the antio of personally what I think
comedy is comedication there's like
making like these terrible situations
funny like I said I I I had to I because
I did the podcast on it I I was forced
to watch that [__] again and it was
fored your trauma dude it's my trauma I
put it out like that Breen shop is
funnier than it yeah yeah 100%
that's the nicest thing you've ever said
about Brendon shop no it's not I said
great things about top 10 heavyweight in
the UFC
okay back down yeah top 10 heavyweight
in the UFC right Brendan sha if you guys
think Brendan sha at least Brendan sha
has punch lines punchin he's trying to
make people laugh he's not just
pandering he's not panding he's not
pandering right so I like H goes up
there and he just jumps up whoa he just
screams up there and he just talks about
his like personal trauma that never
[__] happened yeah like I don't agree
with that not funny and it's just not
funny and also this is another thing
[__] you I always do the Devil's
Advocate I'm I'm good with either side
but um but it's also so hard this is why
sometimes it's so hard to do specials oh
yeah do you know what I mean so it's
like if you do your for I don't know I
think is it second or third I don't know
yeah but but if you do two already
coming up with the third and you're
working on The Daily Show and dude it's
crazy
yeah so he had to be like let's make up
a thing yeah but that's that
doesn't you can make the problem isn't
making things up is making things about
people actual make thing I don't give a
[__] make up something that didn't
happen to you but make it funny and and
also maybe don't involve like some real
people it's like I'm not going to make
up story about me being or I mean I
don't know like feel sorry for me feel
bad for me look how terrible America is
look look we already know like the
inadequacies that this country has right
and there are real stories like that
actually happened why couldn't he just
use that and talk about it in his stand
up why did he have to be the victim why
did he have to be the hero exactly
that's the problem say the an part the
most obnoxious disgusting [__] I've ever
seen in my life and that's coming from
me you know what I'm saying you know
what I'm saying like come on like me I
look at you and I go disgusting got a
problem here yeah you know what I'm
saying and so when I saw that it was
just like it's everything that I hate
about people who try to do new com that
just isn't he's not funny you know what
I'm saying he might be a great writer
all this other stuff but as a standup he
knew he wasn't funny so what he did was
like I'm going to make people feel bad
for me right cuz I can't actually make
people laugh so what I'm going to do is
start pandering to this crowd and hit
their emotional cords and just not make
jokes yeah right trash but this is what
I'm talking
about no none of his stuff has ever been
good it's also it's also that I I don't
know how you feel but this is how I feel
so like look I could like I'm a I'm a
dad right I never call myself a single
dad cuz I think that's that's that leans
into the like make people feel bad for
you yeah it's like I'm already like I'm
a good guy I'm a single dad I also don't
want my daughter to I I could talk about
that and make people feel like oh what a
great guy he is but that energy is dis
like on stage is disgusting to me like
the other night I had a joke and I have
a joke about like the like this these
gay dudes are getting fight in West
Hollywood right and some straight guy
comes off picks on him they beat the
[__] out of him the voice changes they
twerk on his face after whatever it's
just a joke that I do this lady in the
crowd was like like when I said that the
gay dudes beat up the straight dude she
was like yes like yes like that
and it made me so I the fact that she
was agreeing with me like that made me
so mad that I wanted to be like you know
what the gay dudes died in the I wanted
to say that just to make her not like it
just made me mad that she like was like
that's you're good yeah like we're
making this is a joke dude [__] that
energy dude like I hate that
I'm not here to just look like a good
like I want to make you laugh and yeah I
want you to have a good time no doubt
but it's I don't know how to explain it
but it's just like to me that that
emotion in comedy is gross yeah you know
what I'm saying and look if you guys
find like hust like super funny that's
that's [__] dope right no but I just
saying objectively like he gets laugh
from a crowd I I just look at it be
honest with you I've never seen him do
standup outside of his own specials
after he did The Daily Show so who the
[__] really knows right cuz now you have
like your own crowds
right so but I would like to see him go
into a club yeah and make a joke you
know what I'm saying and for me like I
said it just sounds so stupid for me to
even talk about this I just didn't like
the fact that he talked about real life
people people that he knew that was his
he said [__] you to them did his own
thing and made him look better while he
crushed his friends to the floor and he
goes what's the problem it's emotional
truth it happens and I've spoken about
this a lot too just because like as I've
gotten older I've heard so many stories
about like young women who have been
sexually assaulted or whatever whatnot
and how many times have we seen like
these [__] dudes come up and these
girls who actually had like traumatic
experiences that happened to them they
go is it even real is it even true they
immediately call them like they're
[__] liars and [__] right well
imagine like those women were [__]
lying and they go well it happens to
other women yeah so what's the problem
the problem is is that you're profiting
off of this thing that actually happens
to real people exct so like if like if
these women don't get a pass right he
shouldn't get a [__] pass either
right right keep that same [__]
energy that's not fair to [__] women
out I think that's dumb it's [__]
you know what I'm saying so I I don't
know which just also completely
unnecessary to do like you don't like he
went out of his way completely to do
that like it was like why it's like the
Jessie Smo [__] like why Jess why would
you because why are you doing that
there's no need you woke up today
there's no need there's no need but it
evokes human emotions like people say
Tupac was uh not maybe like a better
Lyricist but because of the emotional
thing people gravitate towards that more
and a story that's more personal and I
think that he wanted that to that to
sure but in comedy the purpose is to
make people laugh and if you're not
using it to make people laugh what's the
point at all to sell more to sell
tickets cuz sometimes it's hard to sell
TI and then for people to do a TED Talk
sometimes you know you do the yeah you
know the yeah yeah yeah yeah but you got
to make just say that you want to open
for him
already just Dev Jason's best buds with
them you're an alien dude no
man insir inspirational give me your
hand dude no not the thing no I get it
like I said you know if you like his
stuff you like it I'm just expressing
how I feel about it stuff you know what
I mean and by the way most of the time
like you know I've personally is not my
favorite of course personally it's not
most people's favorites you know what I
mean for anybody who likes to laugh or
you know want to have a good time yeah
yeah you know so but it but when have
you ever heard another comic go like
dude Hassan is [__] hilarious I
haven't heard a single one not all one
but on the same breath it's like good
for him you know he's it's a hard
business to be successful in happy he's
making money good for him yeah it's two
you know but but yeah you're right it's
I get it it's like it's think it's
really gross any kind of pandering [__]
like that I can't I'm like dude it just
almost to me disrespectful to the art of
Comedy D 100% like it's just like what
what what are you doing it's just such a
weird thing to have witnessed and then
for him to just not be like yeah of
course no [__] I was like ah you're an
unfunny person that just wants to be
considered funny and you've been you've
been that guy your whole life yeah you
were the guy that wanted to be the funny
guy nobody laughed at your jokes and
just every day you just wanted to be
that person and so you found a way to
[__] do it yeah right and now you
then you get exposed and you have
nothing to say and in his mind he thinks
it's okay he goes what's the problem
it's emotional truth the [__] that means
it's not true you talk about emotional
truth with your partner and how you feel
you're not real life people and real
life [__] events you [__] [__]
you know what I'm saying like there was
a guy too that was uh he talked about
this whole story of the Moss where he
got slammed onto car or whatever whatnot
because he made a couple of jokes and
there was a guy who was like a CI agent
that was [__] like Incognito that guy
came out he goes I was in jail at the
time like when he said this happened I
never met what is he talking about this
never [__] happened he goes yeah it
didn't happen it's like damn the [__]
are you doing man right so weird yeah
it's like ter it's like like I said the
911 guy you know what I'm saying or like
what if I you know if I told a story
about me getting Asian hate Crim or the
time I got beat up you know Bo get beat
up I you know but David never got beat
up the South pass that dude that [__]
just randomly attacked me right but the
whole point of that there was no joke to
it right I mean it did happen and the
part that I embellished was me saying
that when he crabbed my windbreaker
sounded like he was a DJ at a [__]
club you know what I'm saying that was
the joke you know what I'm saying but it
actually did happen I embellish the
small stupid things you know what I'm
saying and I think that's what most
Comics do unless we're talking about a
stupid hypothetical scenario where Dave
shabelle is grabbing his dick and
shooting that that homeless person
shooting come in a Subway like clearly
this is just for atrics and it's funny I
mean and if it turned out that it wasn't
true everybody's like yeah no [__] it's
not true well even you can tell the
difference even like with the Steve reny
guy like when when they came out that
the 911 story wasn't true which is like
it's same feeling where everyone was
like why why would you lie about that
but that guy seems like a dope dude cuz
he just took it on the chin and he was
like you know what I [__] up I
shouldn't have done that caught up in a
lie he took the licks his friends all
made fun of him he's like [__] it all
right and now he's back he's like that's
like what a guy that like cuz you can
see we're all humans we can all make
mistakes you can lie and you feel the
pressure and he just rolled on with the
LIE shouldn't have done it made a
mistake paid the price they made fun of
him and now he seems like okay cool like
he's like I'm sorry I shouldn't have
done that boom boom boom boom but then
to be like it's just emot like double
down and defend this position where it's
like no dude you're [__] wrong you
should have done that [__] some people
want to sacrifice like being truthful or
authentic for U money or position or do
you know what I mean whatever the thing
is and I think um not that it's okay or
not okay but I feel like some some
people you have to sacrifice a thing
what do you mean I sacrifice
nothing all right yeah this is why I am
the biggest standup comic yeah what do
you mean yeah with some people you have
to sacrifice the thing because I feel
like he is like a person that the
industry loves yeah or did or was still
maybe later but if you is the thing that
industry love then you have to kind of
not say certain things because you're
you know you're in the machine but then
but you just got to then it's like why
are you doing comedy are you doing it
just to be like like what's what's like
why are you doing comedy you know like I
know but people's want is different than
the thing I feel like sometimes I'm too
on the other side I don't want but yeah
but if you're just like but that's but
that's gross isn't it like just to be
like a guy that just makes money for the
machine it doesn't feel good isn't it
kind of not what when you have like a
[__] two compound Mansion thing and
you know I mean and then people's like
this is the best and my people love me
yeah I guess and then you get you get
depends on what
in the streets from a distance those
Tomatoes I'm growing I'm throwing it 100
they're
organic
organic have a St of grape he'll
probably lie about that too and say that
they're GMO
Tomatoes GMO
Tomatoes yeah like you know what also
too it's just like you know there's like
funny things that truth is funny yeah
you know comedy and truth right and
imagine if he did something small like
if he just went like if he made that MOS
story into a hypothetical ended it with
a joke it still would have hit similar
right or it probably would have been
even funnier right yeah but then instead
but once again he chose to do that
because he wants to look like a victim
and he wants to look really good that's
what's gross and that's the gross part
the gross part cuz it's like you could
have just made I I remember uh I was
watching the Andrew Schultz he was
talking about making light jokes about
it obviously he was being very you know
very kind about it but he was just like
your regular life is pretty insane how
come you couldn't just talk about your
regular life yeah right once again
because his regular life doesn't end
with feel bad for me right you know I'm
a good person that's why you know what
I'm saying so I think like you could the
motive the terrible motive is there and
we all see it and a lot of it's not just
us right minus Jason because he's he's
his best
friend I'm in the middle he's Tex right
now these [__] are talking [__] [__]
these I'm throwing a tomato at his
stupid stupid head
but uh I get it you know what I'm saying
I wonder what everybody else thinks in
the com I mean I already did a podcast
on this but you know you know we I could
talk about it all day yeah it's it's
weird it's some weird [__] and it's not
the problem isn't embellishing or lying
it's about people I didn't even know
that the problem I don't even know
enough to know the thing it's not just
the people but it's also the purpose
behind it like why are you doing that
just to get brownie points that's
[__] weird yeah man well guys that
wraps up this episode of The Genius
brain podcast uh you could catch Pat
Patricio SC Riley and Jason chenny at
Jason chenny uh they're all doing stand
up follow them see what's happening in
their stories get the laughs have the
good times uh genius BR every Sundays at
12 p.m. we'll see you all next time
peace